[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
Albus Dumbledore and what his original
wand was made of we know that later in
life
Albus acquires the Elder Wand but what
was the one that he had before that in
Chapter five of the Philosopher's Stone
ones are described as follows a wand is
the object through which a witch or
wizard channels his or her magic it's
made from wood and has a magical
substance at its core once made by
Ollivander have caused a phoenix feather
unicorn hair or dragon heartstring and
are of varying woods lengths and
flexibilities when Albus Dumbledore was
young he met a young Gellert Grindelwald
the pair decided on leading a Wizarding
revolution that would effectively put an
end to the International statute of
secrecy breaking down the secretive
divide between the two worlds however
Albus is sister Ariana was killed in a
three-way duel between Albus Aberforth
and Grindelwald it was at this point
that the boys parted ways Grindelwald
would then go on to steal the Elder Wand
from e.q Kovich who held the wand at
that time Grigorovich the proprietor of
a one shop started spreading rumors
about his possession of the wand hoping
that it would improve business this was
a foolish and fatal error as Grindelwald
stole the wand from his workshop in the
middle of the night the Elder Wand was
the first hallo created made by Death
himself and it was said to be the most
powerful wand that ever existed with it
Grindelwald was able to effortlessly
produce me intensely powerful magic that
other witches and wizards could only
dream of the Elder Wand is made of alder
wood and its core is the tail hair of a
thestral so we know that it's an
extremely powerful wand however we also
know that in 1945 Grindelwald was
defeated despite being in possession of
this wand he was defeated by none other
than Albus Dumbledore so what one did
Dumbledore originally have what was his
one made of obviously Dumbledore becomes
the owner of the Elder Wand after
defeating Grindelwald but the dumb world
that we know and love didn't always
possess it there was a time when
just like every other witch and wizard
Dumbledore went out and bought his very
own first wand
Dumbledore would have purchased this
wand in 1892 at Ollivanders right after
he turned 11 given Dumbledore's age it's
likely that he purchased the one from
Gerald Ollivander the grandfather of
Garrick so Dumbledore's original wand
was just from or one shop there was no
fabled story surrounding it like the
Elder Wand and its association with the
Deathly Hallows that's right it was just
a regular wand but it was still powerful
and its owner was even more powerful
when JK Rowling was asked what
Dumbledore's original one was made of
she responded with the following I must
admit I always wondered why nobody ever
asked me what Dumbledore's wand was made
of and I couldn't say that even when
asked what do you wish you'd been asked
because it would have signposted just
how significant that wand would become
this was a bit of a non-answer and he
got me theorize in and I have a few very
different theories on this topic my
first theory is that dumb models
original wand was related to the Elder
Wand it in some way and I say this
because I think that it could be a
logical explanation for how Dumbledore
ends up beating Grindelwald we know that
the elder one contains a thestral tale
call and we learned from harry and
voldemort unique circumstances that went
once share properties strange things can
happen in the Deathly Hallows
Dumbledore describes the scenario
depicting how Harry's and Voldemort once
interacted Voldemort proceeded to attack
you with a wand to share a core with
yours
and now something very strange happened
as we know the cores reacted in a way
that Lord Voldemort who never knew that
your wonder was the twin of his had
never expected he was more afraid than
you were that night Harry you had
accepted even embraced the possibility
of death
something Lord Voldemort has never been
able to do your courage won your wand
overpowered his and in doing so
something happened between those ones
something that echoed the relationship
between their masters I believe that
your wand imbibed some of the power and
qualities of Voldemort one that night
which is to say that it contained a
little of Voldemort himself so you're
one recognized him when he pursued you
recognized a man who was both kin and
mortal enemy
and it regurgitated some of his own
magic against him so do we just accept
that Dumbledore knows one law
exceptionally well because he's
intelligent and wise or do we perhaps
suspect that he knows it well because
he's experienced some unusual things
with one's first hand if the final duel
with Grindelwald truly became a battle
of wills then I don't know anyone with a
stronger will than Dumbledore
maybe the Elder Wand was more powerful
than Dumbledore's one but the fact that
the two shared a thestral tale core
meant that this didn't matter anymore
since nobody knows how Dumbledore
defeated Grindelwald I think this is a
somewhat logical explanation my next
theory for temples original wand is that
like the ones of many others it was
nothing particularly special and had no
ancient stories tied to it it was just a
regular wand that was a good fit for a
young of the stumbled all long ago on JK
Rowling's website she posted an article
about her discovery of the Celtic
calendar in her article she wrote about
the relationship between different trees
being assigned to different birth months
she also noted that she intentionally
matched Ron and Hermoine Swan woods Ash
and vine to the calendar bearing this in
mind as long as we know when someone is
born we should be able to figure out
what sort of wood their Wanda uses
Rowling has expressed that Dumbledore
was born sometime in late July or early
August according to the Celtic calendar
this would mean that the wood from his
original wand was either Holly or oak
it's a bold assessment to assume that
every character fits this formula but
Rowling has said herself that she
matched Ron and Hermione Swan woods to
this so I think that it gives us a
reasonable base to theorize on
Dumbledore's wand once made of Holly
have been described as follows holly is
one of the rarer kinds of one woods
traditionally considered protective it
works most happily for those who may
need help
overcoming a tendency to anger and
impetuous 'ti at the same time
Holly ones often shoes owners who are
engaged in some dangerous and often
spiritual quest
Holly is one of those woods that varies
most dramatically in performance
depending on the wand core and it is a
notoriously difficult wood
team with phoenix feather as the woods
volatility conflicts strangely with the
Phoenix's detachment in the unusual
event of such a pairing finding its
ideal match however nothing and nobody
should stand in their way Harry Potter's
versed wand was made of Holly and the
fact that Dumbledore had one of his own
could be the reason that he knows so
much about it an oak wand is described
as follows a wonder for good times and
bad this is a friend as loyal as the
wizard who deserves it
ones of English oak demand partners of
strength courage and fidelity less well
known is the propensity for owners of
English oak ones to have powerful
intuition and often an affinity with the
magic of the natural world with the
creatures and plants that are necessary
to wizard kind for both magic and
pleasure the oak tree is called king of
the forest from the winter solstice up
until the summer solstice and it's wood
should only be collected during that
time
Holly becomes king as the day's begin to
shorten again and so Holly should only
be gathered as the year wanes
this divide is believed to be the origin
of the old superstition when his ones
oak and hearses Holly than to marry
would be folly a superstition that I
have found baseless it is said that
Merlin's wand was also made of English
oak though his grave has never been
found so this cannot be proven Rubeus
Hagrid original wand was made of oak the
one that he possessed before it was
snapped and he was expelled from
Hogwarts because oak ones are generally
associated with a love of nature and
woodlands which matches Hagrid nicely
and because Holly wands are often paired
with people who are destined to engage
upon some dangerous and often spiritual
quest I think that Holly is the safe
choice between the two the third and
final wonder would that I think
Dumbledore could have possessed is a
Bini though it contradicts everything
that has been stated about the Celtic
calendar his description seems to match
Dumbledore quite well this jet-black
wand would as an impressive appearance
and reputation being highly suited to
all manner of combative magic and to
Transfiguration
Eponine is happiest in the hand
those with the courage to be themselves
frequently non-conformist highly
individual or comfortable with the
status of outsider
evany wand owners have been found both
among the ranks of the order of the
Phoenix and among the Death Eaters in my
experience the ebony one's perfect match
is one who will hold fast to his or her
beliefs no matter what the external
pressure and will not be swayed lightly
from their purpose given that evany is
highly suited to Transfiguration a
branch of magic that Dumbledore has
mastered I think this one word could be
one to consider so we've got the woods
out of the way and I think that we can
narrow it down to rather safely Holly or
Eponine but one's also come in different
lengths so how long was Dumbledore's
want the following blurb on Pottermore
explains 1 lengths and their
significance most ones are between 9 and
15 inches long one - makers often match
the one length to the height of witch or
wizard who will use it but Ollivander
considers this measure inadequate in his
experience longer than average ones tend
to be drawn to those with a physical
peculiarity or a bigger personality
whereas abnormally short ones select
people whose character lacks in
something because of Dumbledore's
larger-than-life personality I think
that it would be safe to assume that his
wand just like the Elder Wand
is 15 inches long or at least close to
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please remember to
like the video and subscribe to the
channel what did you guys think the
Dumbledore's original one was made of
let us know down in the comments section
below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]